this video is made possible by
Skillshare home to over 17,000 classes
that could help you learn a new life
skill be one of the first 500 to sign up
using the link below and get a two month
free trial with Skillshare
of all the questions mankind has ever
asked one of the biggest and most
fascinating is are we alone in the
universe
it's a hotly debated topic and at this
early stage of space exploration very
hard to answer with certainty but let's
say the world decided to work together
and give it our best shot to find alien
life as quickly as possible where should
we look from what we understand of
biology wherever there is water there is
life so it stands to reason that if we
want the best odds of finding life
elsewhere in the galaxy we should look
for places with water let's start with
the planet we've had our eye on for
centuries our neighbor Mars the red
planet is dusty and barren on the
surface but below the rust-coloured dirt
somewhere around 30 metres down there
could exist pockets of liquid water Mars
also has polar ice caps like Earth and
at some point in its history had oceans
and other bodies of water in November of
2016
NASA reported the discovery of a large
amount of underground ice on Mars the
ice pocket is suspected to contain as
much water as Lake Superior which is a
huge amount of real estate for potential
extrema phial bacteria because of our
proximity to the red planet Mars ranks
pretty highly on our list of places to
explore for life but if we travel a
little further from home we find a
handful of much more promising locations
over 365 million miles from Earth lies
the enormous gas giant Jupiter Jupiter's
orbit is home to not just one but three
potential hot spots for alien life first
the mysterious ice world Europa this
smallish moon is about the same size as
our own moon and is fairly unique in the
solar system as it's thought to have an
enormous global ocean of liquid water in
contact with a rocky sea floor this
ocean is trapped beneath a thick global
sheet of ice which fractures and shifts
as Europa is affected by Jupiter's
gravity the shifting of the tides and
interior of the moon could likely create
volcanic or hydrothermal activity on the
seafloor warming parts of the ocean and
providing essential components for life
the thought of an entire ocean world
beneath the ice just waiting to be
explored is incredibly exciting and has
earned Europa its spot in science
fiction films like the Europa report
next on our list is Ganymede the largest
moon in the entire solar system at 8
percent larger than mercury and about
two-thirds the size of Mars
if Ganymede orbited the Sun instead of
Jupiter it would easily be classified as
its own plan
this giant moon is special because it
likely has an enormous saltwater ocean
beneath it's icy surface so enormous
that it totals more volume than all of
the water on earth scientists suspect
that the ocean is about a hundred
kilometers or 60 miles deep
that's ten times the depth of our own
oceans additionally Ganymede's surface
shows signs of past flooding indicating
cryo volcanic activity another big plus
for life with all that liquid water
hiding below the surface who knows what
could be lurking in the dark depths of
this giant moon the third promising moon
of Jupiter is known as Callisto and
ranks as the third largest moon in the
solar system nearly the size of mercury
in addition to her bronze medal for size
Callisto is also recognized as the most
heavily cratered object in the solar
system proponents of the theory of
panspermia the idea that life on Earth
was sparked via asteroid from somewhere
else
suspect that the same could be the case
for Callisto with even greater odds due
to its huge number of asteroid impacts
and that's not all Callisto has shown no
signs of extensive resurfacing since the
impacts which molded its current
landscape meaning Callisto has the
oldest surface landscape in the solar
system about four billion years four
billion years is a long time for
potential life to develop without
interruption from violent asteroid
impacts and that still not all Callisto
has going for it poor cratered Callisto
once hailed as the most boring object of
its size in the solar system has not
only a subsurface ocean but also a thin
atmosphere of co2 as we've learned from
Earth water plus available co2 is a very
good combination for life
finally we have possibly the best bet
for finding life beyond Earth not
because its conditions are vastly
superior to the other locations on our
list but because this one is literally
blasting hundreds of kilograms of water
vapour molecular hydrogen and other
volatiles into space every second
indicating massive thermal activity
this is Enceladus and it could very
likely be hiding the most exciting
discovery of all time
Enceladus like Europa has a giant global
ocean sheltered beneath a thick layer of
ice but Enceladus is much more thermally
active than Europa one of the most
prevalent theories for the origins of
life on Earth is the idea that chemical
reactions at deep sea hydrothermal vents
provided the nutrients and conditions
for the origin of simple life a theory
published in 2016 suggests that the
Hydra
thermal activity on Enceladus has been
going on since its very formation at
least a hundred million years ago the
presence of such long-lasting thermal
activity on Enceladus has huge
implications in the search for life if
this global ocean and internal heating
have coexisted for tens of millions of
years life would not only have had the
time and conditions to emerge but also
to evolve into more complex forms this
is all incredibly exciting stuff but
what are we doing about it you'll be
happy to learn that the European Space
Agency is planning to send a probe
called juice to Jupiter and its moons in
2022 and NASA hopes to send a probe to
Europa by the mid-2020s as for Enceladus
there's nothing concrete yet but a
number of suggested missions hope to
dive through the breathtaking plumes and
with any luck answer one of mankind's
greatest questions but until then all we
can do is sit tight and wait to discover
what lurks below the surface of these
icy worlds as you all know I'm always
trying to improve my videos without
compromising the fun simple style we all
know and love to do that I'm taking a
class to polish my editing skills with
Skillshare learning by trial and error
is great but when you really want to
fast-track your learning professional
organized classes are the way to go
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators featuring over
17,000 classes and video editing
animation graphic design film production
and more anyone could take a class try a
project or even teach a class themselves
Premium Membership begins around 10
bucks a month for unlimited access to
everything as a little thank you for
watching my videos Skillshare is
offering a 2 month free trial to the
first 500 people who sign up using the
link below you can use those two months
to learn an awesome new skill that you
can use to market yourself create a
business or even start a YouTube channel
like I did there's no better time than
now to take the first step towards
learning that new skill you've always
dreamed of having and since it's
completely free to try you have nothing
to lose be one of the first 500 to sign
up using the link below and start your 2
month free trial with Skillshare if you
enjoyed this video consider subscribing
to keep up-to-date with the latest
content and if you actually want youtube
to tell you when I upload a new video
click the little bell next to my channel
name to join the notification squad you
can watch the rest of my videos by
clicking here or if you're done learning
for the day come check out my new gaming
channel by clicking here thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video